welcome to this video or a 15-minute
game and I'm playing RM and CR omn CRF
favor i played him once before with the
wind and the 15-minute pool okay so i'm
playing the alicorns defense doing
something different and yeah 93 mmm i
actually think that the best move
against this is a 5k going back to be 45
which have played us so often so maybe
just try something else don't want to go
back into e45 territory I mean I if they
do mind really but for the sake of um
playing something else I'd like to very
yeah defo I can take now on c3 yeah i
guess i will getting his pawn structure
somewhat somewhat weakened this is a
good start okay probably the bishop to
g7 know them it's a bit bit like yeah
vaguely like a green felt with the
Knights having taken on c3 and Blackie
and shattering came i'm thinking as i
cancel yeah there is now you always need
to be be aware of h4 h5 moves like that
so i was briefly checking this but not
really dangerous because of age 50 k
bishop to a three addison interesting
move looking at the pawn here on e seven
this is of course a weakness and are not
a terrible one but at least the spot
that he can attack i can I could
actually play Bishop g4 now I couldn't
before because of Bishop f7
now with them castles being played i
could just could play that but i'd like
to address the this Bishop issue I
wonder maybe 97 and c5 the immediate c5
is even interesting Bishop takes Queen
c7 please places him in a somewhat
awkward situation of the sea fowl that's
not bad really c5 maybe maybe this is a
move Bishop takes Queen c7 well now
would he can probably retreat the
bishops Bishop b3 and then but really
but okay if I go see five Bishop takes
Queen c7 instead of threat if I go if he
goes castles for example i played b6 and
he plays Bishop to g5 okay this is a bit
too complicated for my taste mmm I mean
simply because a normal move like this
should be okay so not sure that I need
to do anything anything out of the
ordinary like the immediate c5 this
should be okay really Adam blocks the
path to e7 for the bishop and prepares
Queen Queen 85 then I can play Queen 85
now
yeah I guess that's still a good news I
probably will move the bishop or Quincy
one maybe Quincy one is also move
okay there is no click click on way to
play this may be Knight b6 year yeah
that's a good idea actually Knight b6
attending night to a form directly
directly attacking his weakened
structure yeah that's a good idea
winning a temple beforehand I was only
thinking that II six should be ok like
it six and then just develop night
somewhere f6b should be said but this is
much more much more direct night a for I
am of course dance or in this it is all
coming with with tempo which is very
important ok I can take now and take c3
but now that that's not not totally
clear rook rook here would be three no
but it is good yeah it is good i can go
to a five and the tech a two there will
be some exchanges but at the end it will
open up for my two bishops still still
that let's for a moment think know if i
play something like e6 as a preparatory
move i might play Bishop a 1 SS but ok
it's not really a move that scares me
much yappity six I mean I'd like to play
Bishop e6 maybe I Bishop f5 ok I'll do
that it should be good for black so
so taking here or is them on now is six
maybe obvi should be six yeah but should
be six this may be d5 but that's also
not dangerous hmm yeah I'm a bit a bit
spoiled for choice IAM can play many
moves that make make a pretty decent
impression okay but you also has Bishop
tan look to be five so move like ecigs
would be 523 route c5 is certainly not
bad but also not also not that terribly
great okay I take that the good
additional thing is of course that with
this the default porn is also weakened
very difficult for him to keep the poor
now you will probably need to take here
on let me capture so we have for example
here I can take on deform and this
should be quite good really if on cd4
there is Bishop c4 I can probably play
Quincy five attacking both probably
or is that better movie I can play
something like Queen d8 basically double
attacking e7 and deform ok let's let's
just take your first grabbing the spawn
should be ok 94 s is just just far to
lose this quincy 3 amongst others but 23
Quincy 3 a queen is playing that Quincy
five is just a double attack attacking
the rook and the night I don't I don't
see what he's doing against that guindy
ADA's sir very very similar yeah rookie
form and maybe rookie for it looks it
looks totally artificial but wow that
that's that's maybe a move and maybe
that's a move f5
hmm
look the eight also a routine not sure
the routiers also root d3 so amazing
that's not so easy yeah there is a five
but this I don't know let's technically
lose this proof but maybe if it is just
working I did this not but it does not
matter may I can give the check here but
I think it leads to it leads to nothing
check yeah and now the problem is where
to go with this rook to H form hmm
this could be fun
it's really hit crazy positioned with
other pieces here in the center and
they're all not protected and and
totally strange but yeah yeah I'm still
a bit a bit worried because I have I
don't really have a great coordination
here on the the trucks are not connected
that's the main problem it is I really
don't see any anything concrete but it's
always call cause for concern if not all
our pieces are playing at the rooks are
not connected having the rooks not
connected i'll usually mean sound
background problems and yeah it's not
really happening here but always should
raise your level of alertness of you if
you have this lack of coordination okay
I think I can take the snow see form the
core still hanging after Luke takes
Queen see form yeah now now that that
really should be should be over no
nothing really bad happening here okay
in this position no I cannot do that was
briefly thinking Queen d5 rook g8 and
back rank made but there's rookie seven
so this is not not possible um what's
the best way to do this
yeah probably trade trade trade rooks
that's if he does not take on yet there
is Quincy three okay yeah this is of
course also possible and so let's let's
straight here and now just see that i
get i get queens off this the shirt
should be sufficient if i go Quincy
three intending Queen a one it should be
okay i'm getting ok now i can actually
play Queen a one so okay I'm doing that
getting Queens off shut it should be
pretty easy route b7 I have bishop here
so my bishop is safely protecting the a
porn and I can get rook c8 c2 next or
use the rook against them against the F
to pawn let's say rook c 6-r ook the hd2
yeah if you go see form can i still do
that c5 Roxy tool I don't see I don't
see why not really
it's also
yeah but that's really enough I'm it's
no use of looking for more than one way
to win yeah always must check for tricks
that the pawn is suddenly promoting
after the capture but my route can
always stop it in this side ended
situation check yeah okay so i can check
take here quickly and then then retreat
white resigns yeah this was a very loose
situation in the center all of a sudden
but i think the real problem started
when this in this situation here I came
up I don't really think that this is so
great for wired it still should be okay
because what is so active his pieces are
very active so this structural weakness
is not not great but I don't think white
should be substantially worse and let's
so let's check this again Queenie 5m I
don't know right yet it gets it gets a
bit tricky he may be need to adjust
better to this Queen a5 adium I'm not
sure I mean initially as I said I didn't
think it was so terrible but it it it is
really difficult Queen a five-night b6
is some it's not very comfortable even
sometimes the slow set up with Queen c7
be 66 m
yeah maybe it isn't so right really I
mean around here i did get serious i
mean this is this is already a very
clearly better for black just a matter
of how to do it i mean i was i was a bit
spoiled for choice computer actually I
prefers be six year but I don't think
that this is a mistake yeah okay this
asus is about about about the same value
a powerful black oh and here this is
this is now I'm getting getting really
ugly because he cannot take meanie did
take but it's not it's not really
playable and here when I'm a pawn up and
a to hangs difficult to cover yet after
this that's just material getting lost
computer wants to play Queen D aid maybe
that's even more precise but yeah this
is in fact a bit less precise Queen da
dis better this is also very good but
Queen d8 is better because it does not
even allow Queen rupee five with the
check here at phi this is just an
immediate win yeah okay but it shouldn't
it shouldn't be a real issue right or
here this here there is 96 which are
totally ignored
yeah I didn't think about the move hmm
very strange read something like that
it's a very very weird line the night is
almost wrapped but she can maybe try
that getting it out like this strange
yeah decided that I Queen d8 was much
better and now I'm back on track again
and black ass is winning her minus 4
yeah yeah this just wins a piece now I
didn't do anything wrong after that but
here Quinn d8 was really much much
better and as simply it didn't didn't
think about 96 which is strange it's
very young apparently smooth and the
computer actually prefers be 6 cm not f5
yeah of course if you if you don't win
material f5 is not really a good move
here I just have fantastic structure to
pawn islands against three the bishop
pair and the potential pin on the d far
this is still very very an ammonia sand
I've got we should be saddened coming
with the temple so black is clearly
better yeah I am miss some some chance
to see em didn't play it so precisely um
by the way in the opening year after 93
the I really think that the most
reliable move here is e 5 but after d5
um and I never was so sure what happens
after this here I mean I'm not an expert
in this opening at all but I always
thought that this this might be it might
be interesting something like this is an
owner pawn sacrifice and I'm not sure
that this is really a reliable move it
always felt a bit weird to me so 93 m is
is a move that white players can try
after a five you have this one
I mean the Vienna game is really not
good not great at all but nine m3s is
okay getting back to the the four nights
where you can get interesting play with
Bishop b5 or some lines with deform so
I'm 93 and can be played if you have an
idea against d5 what to do then with e5
you can get in some useful trans
position to e4 e5 if you know those
lines alright thanks for watching